in subscription model the customer pay a
recurring price to have access to the
product subscription provide an
excellent opportunity to create
continued revenue streams which is
wonderful because the lifetime value of
our users will be higher and when users
purchase subscriptions in your Android
apps Google Play handles all the check
out details for you if you have an iOS
app the apple store also does the same
in other words you don't have to
directly process any financial
transactions this ensures a consistent
and familiar purchase flow and improved
user experience it also causes you a lot
less headache some tips for using this
model it is recommended to use a free
trial subscription to allow users to
explore the app first and see the value
you could set a time limit or any other
limit that fit your scenario for example
Dropbox will limit the space you could
use on their free tier due to some
direct carrier billing limits we also
recommend monthly subscription and your
subscription may exceed limits causing
the purchase to be blocked